taking back our streets Mary Jane
beliesza shares the new design on our
roadways aim to curb a legal street
racing
[Music]
[Applause]
stock and that's why we're here
Community leaders coming together to
combat a serious problem
illegal street racing Grand Valley
Parkway and Frontage Road near us-93 has
become a hot spot that's why Metro and
the Nevada Department of Transportation
installed these safety rumble strips we
looked at the wheel path the spinning
radius of a vehicle we tried to put the
rumble strips in between and with the
design of the rumble strips is really
make the car vibrate Mario Gomez is the
district engineer for ndot he says the
intent is to slow down drivers it costs
around seventy thousand dollars for the
for the putting in the rumble strips and
then also we also restripe the
intercession as part of our you know
regular maintenance Metro Police say
they're monitoring this area daily if
effective you could see more of these
safety Rubble ships in our community in
popular street racing areas Metro
officer Darrell Rhodes says Street
Racers with thread truck drivers
delivering supplies by jumping on trucks
even shooting illegal fireworks towards
them so Rebel oil company and the dry
drivers themselves said something has
got to happen something has got to stop
or we cannot deliver fuel to Las Vegas
can you imagine the impact that that
would have on our community to not have
this fuel Clark County Commissioner
Marilyn Kirkpatrick says this is just
the start of a big change as the county
has pushed legislation to fight illegal
street racing it's a lot more than just
taking over the intersection it's what
are they doing and what Havoc are they
causing this is a creative way to see if
this works
now rumble strips are also used on our
highways and freeways to alert drivers
when changing lanes but this is the
first time rumble strips are used to
deter reckless driving